- Yo, how'd your date go?
- It went great man,
thanks. I really like her.
- Nice.
- Yeah.
(suspenseful dubstep)
(gasp)
(suspense music)
- Don't worry guys, she probably
doesn't even know how it works.
- Oh my, look at all these pictures.
- I just shut down the
Wi-Fi for two city blocks.
She's offline.
- No, no, no, she just liked one of my
status updates from two years ago.
- That's impossible. There's a signal
coming from inside the building.
She's inside the building!
(dial-up connecting)
- This thing is so slow.
- What do I even do?
- Ooh, so that's how you upload a picture.
- I just saw your baby junk man (laughs)
- Where are you?
- Stop tagging me in all of your posts.
- I saw your post. I
just want you to be safe.
That's why I'm giving you condoms.
- I can't help you anymore.
- Why not?
- She told my mom to add me too.
(whispers) Now they're
gonna friend all of us.
- Let us in.
- My mom just friended me on Facebook.
- My mom just added me on Facebook.
- My mom added me too!
- Finally, I blocked her. It's over.
(phone buzzes)
- Hi honey.
- Hey babe, what's up?
- I just wanted to tell
you about something
really sweet that happened.
Your mom added me on Facebook,
isn't that great?
- No!
(heart beating)